[Music]
hey Hank I just got to my hotel room in
Kalamazoo Michigan and you know what was
waiting for me here Strawberry Hill
peeps and nerds thanks Kalamazoo and all
evening long I've been thinking to
myself what is it that America wants to
see me do with nerds peeps and a bottle
of Strawberry Hill and then I realized
what America wants to know is whether or
not a peep will float in a glass of
Strawberry Hill will it float
it floats look it's a little ducky on a
pink bond so there you have it Hank
peeps float in Strawberry Hill but wait
you say do nerds Hank as you can see I
have a lot of grape nerds and now we are
going to test them that looks delicious
well Hank the answer is that nerds do
not float except for the lone nerd that
attached itself to the peep smart nerd
Hank many people say the Brotherhood 2.0
is not educational but I would argue
that it is educational because now we've
all learned an important lesson which is
that if you find yourself in the open
ocean with a thousand peeps and a
thousand nerds you should cling to the
peeps and let the Nerds go in profoundly
disturbing news it seems that Strawberry
Hill turns purple nerds white let that
be a lesson to all of you if Strawberry
Hill can strip purple nerds of their
color just think what it can do to your
gastrointestinal system since this is
something from the comments we're gonna
miss U's a Peter writes what if your
efforts to decrease suck levels actually
make suck levels increase what is the
contingency plan we need an exit
strategy here Hank just like Peter I'm
profoundly concerned that we might
accidentally increase suck levels if you
think about it most of the suckiest
things that ever happened started with
an attempt to decrease suck levels like
for instance you have to say that on the
whole the steam engine has been
pretty good thing but then on the other
hand it sure was warm yesterday in
Colorado but here's the thing I'm
thinking the worst thing you can
possibly do is not try to decrease suck
levels after all that's what the first
Brotherhood 2.0 book club book was about
in our lifetimes we're all gonna do
things that accidentally increase suck
levels but the true nerdfighter is
awesome enough to say you know what I've
made a mistake I increased suck levels
worldwide but I didn't mean to I'm sorry
and I think we should change course so
as to decrease suck levels in the future
Hank that's why I'm grateful that so
many people in the American government
are true and awesome nerdfighters oh
wait crap I'll see you tomorrow
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear I'm gonna let
Hank finish the song